[Musique]
quel humour ce nouveau numéro de pas
confiné on va parler de cette france
masqué qu'est-ce que ça va changer dans
nos comportements peut-être à court
terme et à long terme
et puis on pourrait être cassé cette
émission ce saut le pas sous le
patronage pourquoi pas de winston
churchill qui disait ah bah si nous nous
battons pas pour la culture
à quoi ça sert comme ceux de croître et
on va donc parler évidemment que la
situation des décos finement est ce que
c'est un vrai fou déconfinement et puis
beaucoup de cultures avec lionel masse
et à bonjour bonjour vieux mail vous
êtes directeur du théâtre la scène
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui évidemment fermé actuellement
rost bonjour vous êtes climat vous êtes
trappeur vous êtes le président pendu
activé vous êtes aussi membre du conseil
économique et environnemental c'est
comme ça qu'ils s'appellent un ensemble
et avec d'oublier quelque chose
florence vers cadets bonjour bonjour
patrice vous êtes j'aurais dû commencer
par vous vous êtes la seule femme
vous êtes avocate au barreau de
versailles
bonjour stéphane minson bonjour bonjour
à tous
à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin chatoyant
d'ailleurs de donner votre jeune âge et
revues et honoraires en plus ceux qui le
refusent
l'équipe arrive et puis christophe maury
bonjour
bonjour christophe alors vous êtes vous
êtes écrivain vous êtes écrivain de ce
crime et des romans vous inscrire mais
aussi des pièces de théâtre dernière
piste de danse appelée la passation à
c'était la passion pouvoir entre le
président de la république
battus et celui qui doit le remplacer et
puis vous allez publier bientôt leur
mandat qui est au fond l'histoire d'un
théâtre à avignon avec ce festival de
vidéo qui n'aura pas lieu cette année
voilà je suis à peu près sûr vous non
je vous entends pas est ce qu'on entend
christophe maury non mais j'en profite
pour dire bonjour et sur celle de la loi
ni goût je leur ai dit alors vous êtes
un de sedan dans la culture qui va
reprendre le plus vite puisque ledit des
prairies si j'ai bien compris ils
rouvriront le 11 mai voilà absolue mais
en appelant mme attend ça avec
impatience
avec impatience et on parlera évidemment
la situation
la situation des libraires de la culture
de la situation du libre mais peut-être
pour commencer vous pourrez commencer
par le discours du premier ministre
notre jour seuls vrais foudre
déconfinement puisque tout le monde a
tenté cette année 11 mai le
déconfinement allait commencer je crois
que c'est laurent joffrin dans
libération qui dit ah bah finalement le
déconfite mans a toutes les allures d'un
confinement qui ne dit pas son nom
peut-être stéphane minson sur ce sur ce
sujet
oui moi je n'ai pas je n'ai pas regardé
en direct le discours du premier
ministre puisque tu déjà plusieurs
semaines
je m'abstiens et ça ne coûte pas de
regarder la télévision
en revanche ce que j'en ai lu m'a paru
relativement rationnelle à la fois
prudent et empreint d'une certaine dose
de courage je les trouvais surtout
extrêmement clair extrêmement carré et
rigoureux e moi je vous avoue que je
n'attendais pas autre chose
est ce que ce sont des confinement qui
est un vilain mot d'ailleurs qui je
crois ne n'existe pas enfin bon à nous
de le faire vivre si le style nécessaire
que ce second film en je pense ne ne
pouvait pas être conçue comme une
ouverture des vannes l'absolu en
s'imaginant que le 11 mai serait une
espèce non pas de grand soir mais grand
matin où chacun allait pouvoir faire ce
qui voudrait dire à vous comme disaient
les enfants naguère on allait pouvoir ou
est partout en faisant les tags
donc voilà la chose moi me semble
prudente empirique puisque il ya
d'autres choix dans cette période que
celui de l'improvisation dont on ne peut
pas faire reproche au pouvoir en place
d'improviser puisque de toute façon il
n'y a pas d'alternative et que jusqu'à
présent cette improvisation de mon point
de vue c'est pas trop mal trop mal
déroulé sur ce sujet qui veut intervenir
aussi peut-être
moi j'ai suivi le j'ai suivi
l'allocution du premier ministre en
direct
effectivement j'ai trouvé que il avait
alors il y avait déjà ce qui m'a le plus
choqué c'est cette forme de désinvolture
qui l'avait en faisant les annonces et
effectivement d'ailleurs et ian mais
qu'ils sont
on pas empêché de lui dire
qu'effectivement il faisait un exercice
qui n'était pas le sien c'est-à-dire
qu'on lui a donné des maux à dire et il
est prononcé par les mots du président
de la république et il n'avait pas l'air
forcément en accord avec l'ensemble de
ce que lui-même disait et je pense que
le terme d confinement et est un peu
maladroit je pense qu'il aurait fallu il
aurait fallu parler de déconfinement à
l'assouplissement du confinement plutôt
que de parler de déconfinement parce que
là on va pas vers un déconfinement et
puis là il faut savoir que ça sera aussi
malgré tout une liberté conditionnelle
c'est pas on reprend notre vie comme
comme il faut et en plus c'est même pas
encore sûr puisqu'il est le 7 mai il y
aura un point qui sera fait et c'est à
ce moment là qu'ils décideront pas
comment les gens sont déjà beaucoup dans
la rue à partir de la dernière fois où
ils ont parlé d'eux ils ont fait le
discours en parlant du en donnant une
date pour un déconfinement les gens se
sont relâchés et effectivement ça peut
produire des effets pervers
jean charles lajoie denis où mme merkel
n'est pas d'options c'est le sujet je
suis et je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec c'était fade mention sur ce qui n'a
pu dire avec nous pendant avec rod
taylor bas plus de 6 parce que
effectivement on va avoir une liberté
très contrainte et qu' il va falloir
favoriser au maximum ne serait-ce qu'en
matière de d'organisation du travail
favoriser au maximum le télétravail est
donc c'est c'est un travail confiné qui
va se poursuivre mais il est clair que
il faut à tout prix retourner au travail
parce que je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer si je sais qu'il va se passer
dans matière économique et y avoir
énormément de dépôt de bilan et avoir
beaucoup plus de chômage les livrets
chômage parce que là on parle de
millions de chômeurs mais c'est une
grosse partie de chômage partiel
heureusement que sur les 11 millions il
y en a un certain nombre d union qui
vont pouvoir retrouver leur emploi
mais si on se retrouve avec des
entreprises fermées liquide et beaucoup
de chômeurs on va se diriger vers une
très grande précarité une très grande
pauvreté qui est aussi aussi
catastrophique que d'attraper le comité
c'est tout à fait autre chose mais à la
pauvreté la précarité peut durer plus
longtemps que d'avoir levé 19 qui peut
nous immobiliser pendant quinze jours
trois semaines
si on a moins de 75 ou 80 ans donc il
est indispensable de repartir de se re
même de faire repartir les entreprises
quand on voit que avec un confinement de
quinze jours on perd presque 6% bible je
fais pas à fin avril lorsque l'on va
avoir un mois complet de confinement à
quel point le pipe band encore fait
crouler maintenant il faut être
extrêmement prudent et je trouve que
effectivement le discours du premier
ministre est prudent et responsable
il faudrait que chaque français soient
aussi responsables va faire repartir une
deuxième vague ce qui serait
catastrophique pour les hôpitaux parce
qu'à nouveau il faudrait qu'il fasse
cette vague qui reviendrait et où il
aurait de plus grand mal à y faire face
les mêmes que celles à ce que vous
espériez au fond des mesures un peu plus
rapide notamment de cette s'appelle de
50 ans notamment pour la culture pour
les théâtres pour les festivals pétain
on a quelques informations par ailleurs
non moi j'aurais bien aimé qu'il soit
question de culture tout simple bien
dans ce dans ce discours
et il en est très peu question comme il
en est très peu question d'ailleurs
depuis le début de cette crise et de ce
confinement alors même que la culture
représente 1 million et 3 millions 4,1
millions 5 d'emplois directs ou
indirects donc c'est pas totalement
totalement rien et d'ailleurs la
représentation de la culture autour de
cette table ronde ou de cet écran est
quand même est quand même importante
donc je vous en je vous en remercie non
pour l'instant nous on m'a dit qu'un peu
dans le flou j'attendais pas autre chose
en fait parce que je pense que parce que
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le premier
ministre
ce qui est à souligner aussi c'est que
dans son discours ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on est sur une responsabilité
partagée c'est à dire qu'il définit les
grandes lignes mais on aboutit aussi une
responsabilité partagée dans la mise en
oeuvre de ces mesures
donc ça c'est un point qui est quand
même important c'est à dire quand ça ne
repose pas uniquement sur les tables et
services reposent sur un certain nombre
d'acteurs donc pour revenir à la
question culturelle
on navigue totalement dans le flou
aujourd'hui quand alors on a des
éclaircissements sur la reprise des
équipes des théâtres on a absolument pas
de d'éclaircissements sur la reprise des
répétitions aux équipes artistiques
je rappelle quand même que le principe
même du théâtre du cirque de la danse de
la musique c'est être ensemble
travailler ensemble dans la question de
la distanciation physique la
distanciation social est quand même très
très problématique donc on ne sait pas
quand les équipes pourront commencer
recommencer à réinvestir les théâtres et
on sait encore moins quand nous pourrons
recommencer nos activités c'est à dire
ouvrir
sachant que forcément on est en contact
avec télé avec avec des lieux étranges
et d'élus à l'étranger des lieux
européens des lieux voisins qui pour
certains ont décidé de n'ouvrir qu'au
mois de janvier
voilà aujourd'hui on a dit qu un peu
dans le flou d'aucun jour en quinze
jours ce qui crée et je pense c'est pas
de la spécificité du théâtre et de la
culture ce qui crée aussi de l'activité
façon un tout petit peu artificielle et
je pense que dans tous les métiers dans
l'impression et le sentiment de faire de
défaire de refaire de rodez faire de ne
travailler que sur des hypothèses et
c'est ça qui est le plus le plus
stressant non seulement pour l'activité
mais également pour toutes les équipes
puisque au théâtre de saint quentin il
ya 25 salariés
c'est très compliqué de leur dire de
quoi sera fait leur avenir alors moi
j'ai souvent des des mails vous
échangent des coups de téléphone de deux
collègues du théâtre qui me disait ce
que tu en sais un peu plus fine non je
n'en sais pas plus que ce qui est
annoncé par le premier ministre ont par
le président jonathan avait cassé une
grande impatience j'étais très heureux
d'ailleurs que vous citiez cette phrase
de churchill en ouverture de l'émission
j'aurais beaucoup aimé qu'elle soit
prononcée au cours de cette crise si on
ne se bat pas pour la culture à quoi
sert-il de se battre mais je dis pardon
sur celui
écoutez moi je suis absolument
catastrophe en catastrophe et non pas
par le choix politique n est
probablement pas d'autre et et peut-être
que n'importe quel autre homme politique
et n'importe quel autre président
prendrais les mêmes décisions contraint
et forcé par là la pesanteur de
l'opinion publique et delà d'une
certaine veulerie du 2t peuples qui sont
confinés dans une dans une trouille
abyssal mais moi c'est cette survie
qu'on nous propose ne m'intéresse pas du
tout je trouve que on a fait un effort
pendant deux mois c'est très bien ça a
montré ses limites
maintenant tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire de toute façon on va des
cantons des confinera il faudra re
confiné parce que ça va relancer
d'épidémie donc c'est sans fin alors
quitte à ce que ça soit 100 fois vivons
vivons
revoyons nos amis ressortons
laissons-nous libre libre et libre
d'attraper le coronavirus et tant pis je
veux dire c'est je le répète est une
maladie qui épaulent dans 99% des cas
n'est pas létales pendant que jean
charles ça veut dire qu'un poids
politique si je me suis bien puisque 1%
on pourra politique accepterait de faire
six cent mille morts
m on a des tic mais si munich 1% à 3
501% de gens pour lequel c'est grave n'a
jamais parlé de six cent mille morts
reprenons six ans que georges
je pense que jean charles veut dire 1 %
des gens malades c'est tout il ya 1 % et
les révélations qui attrapent qui a
frappé vite pour lequel c'est très grave
alors ce ne sont pas forcément létale
bon maintenant arrêtons cette survie
confiné ne m'intéresse pas c'est pas la
société dans lequel j'ai envie d'évoluer
c'est pas la société dans lequel j'ai
envie que mes enfants évoluent c'est une
société c'est une vie qui n'en est plus
une
alors on peut toujours dire c'est
merveilleux on a le temps de lire en
attente jardine est un phare ponleu ce
n'est pas l'avis que j'ai choisie n'est
pas l'avis que j'ai envie d'avoir alors
maintenant le corps un navire russe il a
bon dos et tout le monde est là en train
de dire mais c'est merveilleux mais
c'est pas grave non non non nous n'en
voyons pas les enfants à l'école ne
retournons pas travailler mais se
précipite on va dans le mur en
klaxonnant là on disant ben là c'est
merveilleux dans six mois le pays sera
je pense qu'il faut inventer un mot plus
fort que faillite pour ce qu'on va être
en train de vivre tous veut dire donc
une catastrophe absolue alors quitte à
arriver vers cette catastrophe ce que
tout le monde nous annonce que tous les
médecins quand par manon les arrivées
d'accord sont là en train de nous dire
que ça va être construit et bien tant
pis mais arrêtons là je dis on va tous
devenir fou et comme le disait et
florence et comme le disait je le
faisais quoi ross à un moment dire les
conséquences pour les gens qui vont
finir par mourir de faim qu'ils vont se
suicider parce que de ne plus voir
personne
les les personnes âgées et qui meurt
dans l'indifférence totale parce que
personne ne va les voir les gens qui
sont dans les deux dans l'est dans les
ehpad qui n'ont plus aucune visite vous
vend content ça leur vie à eux alors
c'est très bien on les protège ou les
protègent de l'état c'est en toi les
faire mourir en avant des bois c'est pas
mieux mais oui mais là mais c'est fini
c'est c'est la négation de la vie celle
ci c'est une seconde je pense qu'il n'y
a aucun pouvoir politique qui pourrait
avoir une gouache de dollars
en tout cas moi je prenne ce jeu est ce
que votre passion sourit pas faire la
solution suédoise neige on dire deux
fois moins de morts en suède
et ils ne sont pas confinés comme nous
alors christophe oreilles ben justement
ce que ce que vient de dire un petit peu
jean-charles c'est que ses bras aux fins
et vous avez publié d'ailleurs un
article dans le figaro
il ya deux jours qu'ils s'appellent nos
bras enfin c'est de dire voilà on a
envie de se toucher de pouvoir se
contacter est ce que vous êtes commun
comme jean charles lajoie ni partie
n'oserait était partisan d'allemand dans
des confinement total est vivant et puis
tant pis l'homme est un être de relation
nous sommes tous interdépendants
nous ne pouvons pas rester confinés et
avoir c'est cette distanciation sociale
le mot est épouvantable nous avons
besoin de deux noms de nous voir de nous
de nous embrasser de nous serrer de nous
serrer la main de maître une tape sur
l'épaule on parler d eux
jean-charles parler très justement des
vieux dans les ehpad
il se trouve que j'ai un ami qui ne
voyant plus sa famille depuis quinze
jours c'est complètement laissé aller il
avait certes 98 mais il est mort dans
une solitude effroyable parce qu'ils ne
comprenaient plus la situation
or il ya quinze jours il allait très
bien enfin il ya deux mois il allait
très bien et sont ses enfants venaient
le voir très régulièrement et bien de ne
plus voir sa famille il a tout lâché
je trouve ça épouvantable que des
parents hummer sans que les enfants les
embrasse les voies enfin c'est le
traumatisme
on ne se rend pas compte du traumatisme
psychologique et social de ce
confinement
alors bon c'est long il faut maintenant
qu'on s'en sorte
c'est à dire on va pas parler en effet
de déconfinement mais il faut que on
s'en sortent c'est à dire qu' on puisse
ouvrir les maisons couvrir les
appartements que les enfants puissent
respirer que tout le monde puisse
respirer
et puis parfois ben oui si elle deuxième
balle y aura une deuxième vague mais il
faut aussi qu'on soit immunisée alors
pendant cette première
ce confinement l'hôpital public a été
sauvée il y avait 5000 lits de dorée à
maintenant il y en a quatorze mille de
plus on a
les infirmières les aides soignants sont
optimaux de basques et de comment donc
on est en fait dans la situation qu'on
aurait dû être
il ya trois mois bon alors repartons et
puis oui aura des morts bon ben c'est la
faute à pas de chance c'est c'est la
nature
c'est terrible à dire mais on ne peut
pas continuer comme ça nos bras enfin et
surtout nos esprits son robot low alors
florence a raison il faut y aller sur le
plan économique roce tu as raison il
faut y aller sur le plan social
lionel a raison il faut se rassembler se
réunir et communier ensemble peut-être
d'une autre façon mais on va on va y
réfléchir en la vente et stéphane la
raison de parler de ceux de ceux du
premier ministre qui a été à la fois
très clair très pédagogue
attention cependant à ne pas trop nous
infantiliser or je trouve que le
discours des politiques a tendance à
nous infantiliser en disant vous devez
faire ceci ou de faire cela mais
attention mais pas ceux ci pas cela
alors on nous avait d'énormes on nous
met des procédures nous et ça au bout
d'un moment ça fatigue les gens donc
laissons les gens un peu libre et
surtout rappelons nous que nous sommes
interdépendants et que l'homme est un
être de relation stéphane manceau et je
ne sais plus où est passée rost c'est
maintenant sûr là dessus vous pensez que
voilà encore au peu cette sorte de
libéralisme politique que promeut que
provenir jean charles hey hey hey hey
christophe maury lane où il ya deux
observations pendant ce que je viens
d'entendre à propos de ce que je viens
d'entendre
alors je c'est vrai que nous sommes nous
sommes des êtres sociaux way et on sait
très bien
l'ethnographie l'ethnologie
l'entrepreneur gilles ont bien mis en
évidence si on laisse un jeune nouveau
né sans aucune relation sans aucune
interaction puis par mourir il ya déjà
eu des expériences de ce type là qui ont
été conduites bon donc nous sommes des
êtres vivants des animaux
essentiellement sociaux nous nourrissons
de l'interaction avec l'autre ça c'est
incontestable mais d'une part est-ce
qu'on est infantilisé ça je ne le crois
pas moi je
il me semble toujours que ce que la
démocratie porte aux manettes porto de
pouvoir sont un miroir de ce que nous
sommes et je ne sais pas où est la plus
forte
infantilisation si elle se trouve du
côté des pouvoirs politiques ou bien du
côté du corps social du corps électoral
du côté des citoyens le on entend tout
et son contraire on veut tout et son
contraire et il appartient évidemment
aux pouvoirs politiques de cheminer sur
une ligne de crête ce qu'ils s'efforcent
et je mets ce qu'il faut plus rien dans
la vision dans la plupart des états
démocratiques
celui que ses forces de faire tant bien
que mal et puis il ya une seconde
observation sur le le pire nations chan
qui nous disent finalement voilà pendant
45 jours presse de 50 jours maintenant
nous avons été reclus et bien maintenant
ouvrons les portes
ouvrons grand les fenêtres et sortons
aimons nous embrassons nous travaillons
d'accord il y aura des morts et tant pis
parce que la vie est ainsi faite parce
que la mort est inscrite dans ce qu'une
chambre et c'est vrai que compte ce
qu'on ville les crillon on ne me fera
pas de mal a dit on meurt
essentiellement parce qu'on est en vie
on m'avait dit ça c'est vrai mais sauf
que c'est un peu dommage parce que c'est
au fond gaspiller les 50 jours que nous
devons de passer et nous risquons en
effet de mettre à bas
d'annuler les effets positifs qui ont
été produits qu'on le veuille ou non
parce qu'on filme en une troisième et
ultime observation c'est que derrière
tout cela et christophe notamment on a
parlé
derrière tout cela il ya le service
public de santé
et c'est sur lui que jusqu'à présent
nous avons étalonner toutes les mesures
qui ont été prises à savoir les
capacités d'admission en soins en soins
intensifs en réanimation et on ne compte
je crois que le corps électoral le corps
social que l'opinion publique plus
largement ne ne sont pas prêts à
accepter une situation dans laquelle le
service public de santé notre service
public hospitalier dire hé hé bien non
nous n'avons plus les moyens de vous
soigner nous n'avons plus les moyens de
vous admettre en soins en soins
intensifs en réanimation
on a déjà fait le reproche au service
public hospitalier de sélectionner entre
les différents malades entre ceux qui
auraient entre guillemets droit ou pas à
des services de réanimation ce que on
dit par ailleurs et nous le savons tous
c'est que en dehors des périodes de
crise
cette sélection entre nîmes et se faire
simplement elle revêt aujourd'hui un
contraste plus saisissant et cela ça a
choqué alors est ce que nous sommes
prêts à accepter que notre service
public de santé que trois extrêmement
performant en dépit de tout ce qu'on a
pu dire
puis nous dire à un moment donné au
regard de l'afflux de victimes et sans
compter les morts on tombe aussi les
malades
je ne crois pas que nous sommes prêts à
entendre
et bien non là nous ne pourrons plus
vous admettre à l'hôpital on peut plus
vous transporter vers l'ouest de la
france parce que tout est saturé il ya
plus de place débrouillez vous mais
aimez vous embrassez vous et
restons confinés pendant trois ou quatre
ans voilà où nous attend on attend un
hypothétique vacances demain et dans
quatre ans on se revoit et on en parle
sur les roses paraît que vous êtes
mordus du conseil et économiques
environnementales et sociales ou
sociales et environnementales
peut-être parce qu est ce qu est ce qui
n'est pas justement dans une dans une
période assez complexe pour les
gouvernants c'est à dire que l'on
gouverne sans rien savoir les
scientifiques eux-mêmes apprennent tous
les jours sur le sur le virus et des
informations souvent contradictoires
donc on a un pouvoir qui est face à
l'inconnu c'est c'est très tendu très
difficile de gouverner par rapport à ce
qu'on ne sait pas non mais je pense
qu'on est dans un pays où il ya une
espèce de schizophrénie permanente au
vote et le lendemain on gueule et ont
décrit les gens pour qui on vient de
voter pour eddy jean charles et le une
partie de la france
si ces mesures n'avaient pas été mises
en place moi vous ne connaissez je suis
pas un fervent défenseur du pouvoir même
si voilà parce que je trouve que ce
qu'ils font depuis depuis leur accession
au pouvoir extraordinaire par rapport
aux attentes qu'on avait et l'espoir que
quelqu'un ait suscité emmanuel macron
lorsque nous nous sommes tous engagés à
l'époque à le à le soutenir et à faire
changer le système a pété le système
entre guillemets et aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que c'est encore pire que
les autres mais sur ceux sur cette crise
moi je veux qu'on est quand même un
minimum d'un pull chance c'est que
personne n'avait les éléments pour
prendre des décisions précises regardez
comment a été décrié boris johnson sur
sa gestion du début de la crise en
angleterre et aujourd'hui on dit ah ben
on aurait dû faire la même chose en
france
vous parlez des cieux doit tout à
l'heure mais les suédois n'ont pas du
tout la même discipline n'ont pas le
même civisme que les français c'est
comme si vous compariez la france à la
suisse les suisses tu respecte beaucoup
de choses que les français ne respectent
pas du tout on n'a pas du tout là notre
adn n'est pas est pas pareil
les cieux douanes sont un peu plus froid
que les français habituellement
donc il ya une espèce déjà de
distanciation social qui était naturel
au niveau de la population ils sont
moins nombreux donc on n'a pas les mêmes
on peut pas on peut pas gérer les choses
de la même manière
regardez ce qui se passe entre la
catastrophe qui est en train de se
passer aux états unis c'est hallucinant
quand vous avez un président de la
république qui appelle à se révolter
contre le confinement
parce que eux ne sont que dans des
intérêts économiques donc je pense qu'il
faut quand même qu'on met tous tous
autant que nous sommes un tout petit peu
d'humilité face à cette situation et il
faut essayer d'accompagner les mesures
de manière à ne pas rendre les choses
encore plus anxiogène que ça ne l'est et
essayons en tout cas de 2 mais parce que
je suis sûr que vous aurez vous auriez
été le premier à monter au créneau pour
dire ah mais ils ont laissé les gens
mourir sans rien faire donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ait tous conviennent
tout ça un peu d'humilité
jean-charles avec votre nouvelle pub
elle vous allez rester confiné combien
de mois alors heureuse pour eux sauvé
avant 2025
et ben voilà c'est très bien c'est
parfait c'est une très bonne idée
c'est une très bonne idée récit et
continue et puis on se téléphone à une
fois tous les deux ans pour voir si la
ligne fonctionne toujours et on
regardera par la fenêtre les débris les
suicides des gens les les pauvres hères
mourant de faim et le et l'économie au
delà de dudu du zéro non mais je
voudrais juste préciser une chose je ne
critique pas se casser ni macro ni loire
philippe ils ont probablement fait ce
qui est ce que l'urgence réclamer de
faire et c'était très bien
ils rue ce confinement de deux de deux
mois à peut-être été
on verra l'histoire jugera mais est
probablement une bonne idée
peut-être n'y avait-il pas d'autres
solutions et maintenant il faut en
sortir parce que je vous dis encore une
fois sinon vous avez tous raison c'est
très bien pour limiter pour limiter la
maladie on ne sort plus et il est même
pas besoin de s'emmerder à trouver un
vaccin ne dépensons pas l'argent qu'on
n'a pas trouvé un vaccin responchons
nous économisons mais rodilhanais saint
cornier toujours alors chacun une belle
bibliothèque un beau jardin etc
c'est très bien penser un petit peu à
dire des gens qui rend un peu envie
d'autre chose on se perd gagne
oui alors je suis parfaitement d'accord
avec ross est ce que je voulais ajouter
c'est que on a effectivement un discours
réaliste et anxiogène et je trouve qu'il
manque de la part des politiques aussi
un discours mobilisateur dynamique et un
peu positif pour essayer de partir sur
l'avenir et du coup uniquement avec un
discours un peu anxiogène
très honnêtement je me dis qu'après le
déconfinement va avoir une vie qui va
pas drôle du tout bon alors je ne vais
pas anticiper donc c'est donc de base
que je veux dire qu'il n'est pas du tout
discours mobilisateur entraînant
dynamique et pour soutenir un
rassembleur pour soutenir je parle sous
le contrôle de stéphane mention mais je
pense qu'il ya justement entre le
premier ministre le président de la
république peut-être deux rôles
différents le premier mise qui est en
train de gérer les affaires courantes
c'est à dire il faut des décisions au
jour le jour et est peut-être emmanuel
macron qui dit le jour d'après n'a pas
la même chose que le jour d'avant se
dire qu'ils pensent aussi peut-être
basse que ce que sera la société de
demain dieu mais c'est parce que
justement la culture jeudi le monde est
dans une période d'incertitudes absolues
est ce qu'il ya des déchets pas des
pièces de théâtre par exemple qui nous
raconte sa kinois quand il a la
certitude du pouvoir ou la difficulté du
pouvoir
je pense qu'il rend partie du théâtre
occidental parle de ça oui oui c'est la
culture pour tous et la culture nous n
je pense que je pense quand on parle la
culture et l'art je pense quand on parle
de quand on parle de lire alors c'est
vrai que moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour pour tous ceux qui arrivent à
trouver le temps de répondre à toute
cette offre culturelle et artistique ya
sur les réseaux qui allie arrive à lire
30 bouquin dans la semaine et cetera et
cetera je sais pas comment ils font
mais mais en tout cas la culture et les
que je pense est assez avec une des
valeurs sont assez présents dans notre
dans notre quotidien
donc oui ça une part sa une part
extrêmement part extrêmement importante
après dans l'art que je défends c'est
aussi un art du rassemblement je pense
pour revenir sur ce que j dont je disais
on se disait jean charles ce que des
effluents ce certains discours qui
anxiogène on peut aussi inverser la
façon de le qualifier et qui est de dire
que c'est un discours responsabilisant
j'aimerais bien moi que ce discours
responsabilisant tel qu'il est tel qu'il
est 10 / / / cette crise soit le même
sur par exemple l'écologie moi je trouve
que cette idée de responsabiliser le
citoyen est extrêmement importante à la
fac du colibri de cher à pierre rabhi
d'autre part c'est vrai que l'idée de se
dire voilà sortons embrassons nous c'est
super effectivement c'est très ccc
extrêmement courageux je pense que ce
serait le pire de ce qu'est le
libéralisme c'est à dire que finalement
laissons faire les choses les soins fr
on allait et ce qui arrive à s'en sortir
ils s'en sortent non là je pense qu'on
est dans une phase qui est aussi une
face d'espoir qui est la phase de
déconfinement canton dirigeants théâtre
on est véritablement au coeur de sa au
coeur de ce qu'est le rassemblement nous
on a envie de toucher les gens
intellectuellement sensiblement mais pas
physiquement c'est à dire non aussi
envie lorsqu'ils viennent au théâtre qui
soit totalement voilà totalement
libre qu'il puisse être là
tranquillement et profiter de ce qui se
passe sur scène donc on a une
responsabilité qui est extrêmement forte
nous on est les premiers à souffrir de
cette de ce confinement puisque le
métier qu'on a choisi c'est le métier du
rassemblement maintenant on a envie
aussi que au moment où pourra se
rassembler on puisse le faire de façon
tout à fait naturelle et j'espère que
l'on va vers ça je pense que le monde
après six monde d'après il ya je pense
que le monde appréciera certainement
pire que le monde d'avant mais ça c'est
une autre histoire
je pense qu'on se on repart vers 7 vers
cette normalité
effectivement il va falloir faire
attention pendant un an deux ans c'est
notre responsabilité je pense qu'on fait
pour une fois considérés comme des êtres
reponsable de ce qui se passe et ça
c'est important de le dire parce qu'à
peu de pouvoir et là c'est pas une prise
de position pour ou contre macro ans et
vis à vis de ce pouvoir peu de pouvoir
qui ont un discours aussi
responsabilisant que le discours l'est
aujourd'hui et pour reprendre ce que dit
ross effectivement moi j'habite j'habite
montmartre lorsque un samedi après midi
à 18h quelqu'un mais la musique à fond
sur sa terrasse et que 30 40 personnes
se réunissent et se met à danser sur la
place constantin pecqueur oui il ya
quelque chose d'assez désolant de se
dire que parallèlement à ça moi j'ai des
amis qui sont urgentistes et qui ont
souffert pendant deux mois trois mois
alors je veux bien qu'on lâche tout
qu'on libère tous et qu'on se dise les
urgentistes et le monde hospitalier il
se démerde ce n'est pas notre problème
si c'est notre problème aussi c'est
notre problème à ce que la question de
la santé fait totalement partie de notre
responsabilité aujourd'hui et on le sait
donc on ne peut pas se limiter un
discours qui dirait soyons libres
embrassons nous mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi c'est notre responsabilité en voir
les conséquences et faire en sorte que
petit à petit on se redirige vers cet
être ensemble qui est si important ainsi
chers à nos yeux et nos vies
hip hop une petite intervention sur ce
que disent et lionel bah c'est à mes
yeux je pense que vous avez non
seulement réseau et je trouve assez
ridicule que ce soit sans doute les
mêmes qui applaudissent le gie soir à
20h l'aider les médecins et des
infirmiers de ça et qui vont danser
après c'est comme sur les places comme
ça alors on fait non l'autre mais il
faudrait peut-être choisir pardon
florence non mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec lionel sur le partage de
responsabilités entre les citoyens et
les temps mais là où je suis un peu
choqué c'est que l'état se décharge de
sa responsabilité sur les parents par
rapport au fait de scolariser les
enfants ou pas il à dire que l'état dit
aux parents s'ils voulaient scolarisés
c'est sur le volontariat et c'est à vous
de prendre la décision et on va
retrouver effectivement une cassure mais
ils ont été conseillés par jean charles
lajoie ni minorité le gouvernement
propose d ouvrir la garderie pardon
l'école donc voila c c'est une chose
claire et nette
les départs en ont l'air de découvrir ce
que c'est un globalement que c'est
compliqué d'avoir des enfants on se
c'est assez curieux cette année un un
enseignement de du confinement tous les
gens sont là dedans mais c'est horrible
on a nos enfants toute la journée
et pourquoi est ce que tous ces gens ont
fait des enfants kouassi salaisons si ça
les emmerde perdure pendant toute la
journée
mais pourquoi s'ils en ont deux trois ou
quatre c'est totalement scandaleux ces
attitudes de parents c'est une honte
jean-charles non mais ce que tu veux y
avoir une cassure entre eux ce qu'ils
peuvent garder leur enfant est en
difficulté ce ils ne peuvent pas garder
leurs enfants et qui doivent retourner
au travail même s'ils veulent pas les
remettre à l'école ils vont être obligés
de les remettre à l'école c'est en fait
reposer sur les parents cette
responsabilité mais il ya juste une
donnée florence qui est différente ou
qui est nouvelle c'est une question de
santé
et est ce que les parents
prêt ou pas à faire prendre le risque
aux enfants de contracter le virus donné
qu'ils n'étaient pas avant et qui
n'étaient pas avant avant avant le
d'épidémie donc c'est une situation tout
à fait nouvelle si cette question de
volontariat c'est une situation qui va
être temporaire oui mais elle est ainsi
bien l'état nous dit bien faut rester
confinées pour des problèmes de santé
mais là en l'espèce il laisse les
parents prendre cette responsabilité que
je trouve un peu choquant je pense de
responsabilité là il peut y avoir des
lectures de ça alors évidemment il ya
une première lecture qui est qui les
enfants étant entre guillemets moins
exposé
et qu'il faille que qui est une partie
de la population qui contractent le
virus pour qu' il y ait cette barrière
naturelle donc peut-être qu'il ya cette
stratégie il ya une autre autre chose
derrière c'est que vous avez des écarts
des inégalités qui sont en train de se
creuser de façon monumentale et le
problème est là sauf que en permettant à
certains d'aller à l'école et d'autres
pas les familles qui ont les moyens vont
pouvoir garder leurs enfants vont moins
les exposés au risque et du coup c'est
encore les mêmes qui vont encore prendre
les mêmes risques et qui vont encore
payer le prix le plus fort et c'est ça
le problème mais des 10 c mais en même
temps
c'est compliqué et compliqué de trouver
une solution adéquate
oui jean-charles vous me fait toujours
rire parce que vous êtes toujours dans
l'extrémité on fait des enfants certes
mais c'est pas pour autant que moi je
suis ravi de me publier sur ma page
facebook un article là dessus sur le
fait que justement cette situation
permet aux parents qui passent leur
temps à décrier les enseignants le corps
enseignant de voir à quel point ils ont
une patience à toute épreuve et ça leur
permettra de respecter le corps
enseignant et de voir le boulot est fait
au quotidien
la suisse attend pourtant même pour ça
c'est ce que le virus est et vertueux
sur le mouillé d'après certains
gisements lyonnais leurs vieux pas parce
que disait lionel justement parce que le
monde d'après juste qui est en train de
se passer là déjà pendant le lait
pendant la crise le comportement des
gens avec la délation permanente calme
explosé et puis les la violence des
propos des uns des autres
le comportement des saints de certains à
l'extérieur et des gens qui les
soignants qui reçoivent des lettres
dans leur boîte ou sur leur voiture leur
demandant de quitter leur domicile parce
que ils sont au contact des malades
oui effectivement ça n'augure pas de
deux jours meilleurs
très prochainement en tout cas donc
j'espère j'espère que on se trompera
tous et que ça sera mettons le moment de
reconstruire un autre monde que ce que
celui celui d'avant alors justement
réunir cet autre monde
d'abord il va falloir peut-être trouvera
un vivre différemment peut être un
ferment de la culture différemment
christophe maury vous avez lancé un
groupe sur balzac alors au départ
c'était vous qui disiez des des textes
notamment de maupassant
c'était formidable et puis y'a pas mal
d'acteurs qui sont venus sur ce groupe
qui disent des poèmes qui qui alors
qu'ils détournent un peu on va regarder
juste un petit peu un petit excès de ce
café de francis huster
c'est un extrait du misanthrope d'une
misanthrope pendant et il le fait d'une
façon assez contemporain non on regarde
si on a peur de ce qui va changer
qu'est ce gant
qu'avez-vous mais c'est moi tout prix
mais encore dites moi quelle bizarrerie
laissez-moi vous dise et qu'on va vous
cacher on dort moins les gens sans se
fâcher moi je vais me fâcher et veux pas
te rendre dans vos brusque chagrin je ne
puis vous comprendre et quoique amis
enfin ces sites ou des premiers mois va
travailler cela vos papiers
j'ai fait jusqu'ici confessions de
l'être mais après ce que je viens de
paraître je vous déclare dette que je ne
suis plus élevés d'une place dans les
choeurs candy je suis donc bien coupable
cest pas votre console et vous devriez
mourir de pure honte une taxe ne serait
s'excuser et d'analysé
ah c'est cette image et à sa vie
d'enfant
est-ce que amusante et parlons est ce
que l'on va assister au théâtre avec des
acteurs qui auront des masques pas
l'esprit leur offre ça nous fera
beaucoup rire mais c'est très nouveau
encore que ça va alors peut-être que le
jour où on aura trouvé un vaccin ou le
virus a dit fan parce qu'il peut aussi
disparaître tout va reprendre un peu
comme avant comme on dit où elle même
mais il ya va bien y avoir une période
compliquée il va falloir s'adapter quand
comment vous allez le faire vous au
théâtre vous allez faire quoi
une place ion 2 comment comment comment
vous imaginez ça la première chose c'est
quand on regarde un francis huster là ça
m'a fait me fait beaucoup rire mais il
vous faut pas anticiper nous sommes
capables de nous habituer à tout y
compris à ne pas rire devant francis
huster en train de dire le misanthrope
avec en basque et ça peut être que dans
six mois noté jacques bon voilà on
s'habitue absolument tout alors imaginez
vous patrice venir au théâtre on a la
grande salle fait mille places c'est un
grand poids on limite la jauge un siège
sur deux sièges sur trois c'est-à-dire
qu'on à 300 400 personnes en salle avec
une distanciation social pour rentrer en
salle c'est à dire que vous commencerez
à faire la queue à la sortie de tv 78 il
faudra une personne tous les to les
mettre tous les mètres 50 dont vous
mettrez à peu près une heure une heure
et demie pour rentrer en salle est à peu
près peut-être pas le même temps mais
trois quarts d'heure pour en sortir
donc d'un point de vue technique c'est
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui nous
semble impossible et puis ensuite ce qui
nous semble être un repoussoir pour les
pour les publics
mais là encore on peut pas anticiper
notre capacité à tous nous allons nous
adapter absolument à toutes les
situations et notamment dans le
spectacle on s'est dit on s'adapte à
tous d'y circuler les situations et si
on nous demande du jour au lendemain de
bon voilà vous avez la possibilité
d'accueillir 50 % d'âge mais en
respectant un certain nombre de normes
on le fera parce que ce qui compte avant
tout pour
c'est de pouvoir avoir des comédiens sur
scène kansai et de faire en sorte que
les artistes puissent travailler c'est
notre travail donc on s'habituera même
si aujourd'hui ça nous semble absolument
impossible inimaginable et être en route
pour soi et pour les publics et pourrait
peut-être pas pour les artistes les
artistes ont besoin aussi travailler
très tôt mme maury juste le festival
d'avignon qui m'a pas avoir lieu cette
année
c'est simple vous avez été le mien coeur
de la librairie théâtrale pendant très
longtemps
c'est un vrai problème comme pour les
acteurs pour les metteurs en scène pour
tous ceux qui concourent à la halle aux
grains culturel oui alors il se passe
quelque chose d'absolument passionnant
ce moment on a vu francis huster eux
dans le misanthrope et vous parliez de
ceux de ce groupe en effet la lecture en
confinement que j'ai dansé avec hervé
masquelier qui a monté lui-même my
little tv qui est sûr sur youtube pour
pouvoir lire des textes je crois qu'il
faut repenser le geste théâtral dans une
urgence et actuellement il ya énormément
de propositions avec beaucoup de talents
de créativités à la fois de que l'on
voit sur youtube notamment deux
comédiens qui ce qui arrive à se mettre
ensemble grâce au nouveau aux nouvelles
technologies et qui arrive à faire
passer une émotion un texte des mots et
qui arrive finalement à nous rassembler
d'une autre façon repenser le geste
théâtral sait aussi rassembler des gens
peut-être sur une place peut-être dans
sous une halle en tout cas plus dans des
petites salles plus dans des salles qui
ont une scène et un public vous parliez
tout à l'heure
lionel de la difficulté de faire rentrer
les gens de faire sortir les gens
et qu'est ce que l'on fait pour ceux qui
veulent aller aux toilettes par exemple
ça va être très très compliqué au moment
de bon donc tout le la place du théâtre
la place dans le théâtre le théâtre tel
qu'il est placé aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne plus
le comédien lui demeure le texte lui
demeure place le la
volonté et l'émotion tout ça demeure
donc il faut le réinventer totalement
tout est ouvert
alors pourquoi pas aussi vous êtes aussi
un homme de scène
vous avez donc je pose des témoignages
de collègues et vous qu'est-ce que
québécois là il ya une angoisse
justement ne plus pouvoir faire ce
métier là bas tout de suite alors tout
dépend du niveau des artistes
vous avez des artistes qui ont de
l'argent de côté qui est qui ont pas
qu'ils sont pas plus angoissés que ça et
vous en avez d'autres types qui
quotidien de leur métier
donc c'est pas la même c'est pas du tout
la même situation vous avez une
situation de précarité là pour beaucoup
de gens en plus avec les nouvelles
conditions par rapport au statut
d'intermittent fait que certains sont
sortis de du statut et donc leur
situation est beaucoup plus complexe
d'ailleurs vous invite à lire l'article
que j'ai fait pour le numéro spécial de
stratégie sur la culture et l'impact de
la culture sur nos sociétés et
l'évolution de nos sociétés
c'est un numéro spécial qui s'appelle
les engager une 15 ans gars j'ai et donc
vous verrez ce que disait tout à l'heure
lionel masse état et et je partage à
1000% le le rôle de la culture dans
toutes les sociétés dans toutes les
crises cc c'est une des choses qui
permet aux gens d'ailleurs dans les
moments les plus compliquées de tenir le
coup si vous n'aviez pas de la lecture
si vous n'aviez pas de la musique si
vous n'aviez pas les films c'est ça
serait compliqué jean-charles je crois
qu'il se serait jeté par la fenêtre
depuis très longtemps mais le dire il y
en a on a on a ce socle là qui est
important est la situation elle va être
quand je vous parlais tout à l'heure de
la question sociale
il va y avoir une déflagration sociale
extrêmement violente
parce que tu es ce que ya des situations
dans les banlieues dont certaines
banlieues qui vous paraissent et qui vit
au naturel inquiétante mais vous avez vu
d'ailleurs une sas a brûlé un peu la
danse
dans certaines banlieues et alors je
t'aime le je vais juste dire un petit
truc là dessus je trouve que la manière
dont le gouvernement a géré la question
des banlieues
au départ je trouvais qu'elle était elle
était la bonne manière
il ya des gens qui ont mal vécu le fait
que un moment ils disent le confinement
dans les banlieues n'est pas forcément
une priorité
alors j'ai je m'explique c'est que
effectivement ça peut choquer des gens
et même les gens dans les banlieues qui
disent que c'est parce que on est des
citoyens de seconde zone ils voient les
choses de cette manière là non moi je
pense qu'ils ont pris acte d'une chose
fondamentale c'est que que vous habitiez
un appartement de 120 mètres carrés ou
une maison en banlieue ou dans une
banlieue chic où que vous soyez à la
campagne
le confinement n'est pas forcément le
même vous avez des gens qui vivent à six
ou sept dans 30 ou 40 mètres carrés et
qu'ils ne peuvent pas rester toute la
journée en plus quand vous avez des
enfants c'est très très compliqué donc
j'ai trouvé que cette espèce de petit
souplesse qu'ils avaient un moment était
nécessaire et impératif pour pas que les
chose faite
mais là la situation sociale dans ces
quartiers là elle s'est dégradée et vous
aviez plein de gens qui gagnent très
très peu d'argent et en faisant des
petits boulots
aujourd'hui n'ont plus rien et là on
encore voir d'ailleurs heureusement
qu'il ya une espèce de solidarité qui
s'organise aussi dans ces quartiers là
sinon je peux vous dire que c'est
s'arrêter mais la sortie moi je redoute
fondamentalement la sortie dans
certaines campagnes et dans les
banlieues
florence et et lorsque vous demandez
dans un instant peut-être qu'est ce qui
va changer dans les relations du travail
et et stéphane dans les lettres dans
l'enseignement mais j'aurai un noir avec
jean charles lajoie ni disait ce matin
xavier bertrand qui propose un grand
plan de relance de l'édition avec
notamment
1 une politique d'incitation à la fin du
libre est ce que vous êtes éditeur
c'est vrai que la situation des éditeurs
et des libraires et des nous avons
rouvrir à redemander été très compliqué
dans les semaines qui passait est-ce que
vous inscrire pour justement un grand
plan de relance de l'édition wii vient
tu bien évidemment je suis surtout si ce
que vous dites s'avère exacte si on
incite les gens à acheter des livres
alors par je ne sais quels moyens je
n'ai pas encore lu la tribune xavier
bertrand de piste mais bien évidemment
plus les gens vont dans les
bibliothèques les enfants dans les
librairies plus les gens achètent de
livres
mieux on se portera et toute la chaîne
du livre se portera mieux parce qu'il
faut faire attention à une chose c'est
que j'aime bien évidemment énormément
tous nos amis libraires mais faudrait
pas a résumé le monde de la criée du
livre ou problème des commerces et des
librairies
parce que dans les librairies on vend
des livres il faut pas encore qu' aucun
libraire puisse vivre il faut qu'on
puisse leur fournir des livres
et voilà donc nous ne nous focalisons
pas uniquement sur le problème des
librairies mais si ce problème de
l'édition de la distribution de la
diffusion c'est une chaîne nanterre on a
toujours tendance à ne voir que le
commerçant excellent dans ses librairies
mais avant les livres il faut les faire
il faut que les auteurs puissent d
écrire il faut qu'on puisse les publier
il faut qu'on puisse relancer la machine
et n'aura effectivement toute initiative
est bonne
après deux dans l'est dans l'état dans
lequel nous sommes tous bien évidemment
chacun va presser va prêcher pour sa
paroisse visiblement les cordons de la
bourse sont ouverts puisque la bourse
est sans fond donc oui pourquoi pas de
nom de notre argent à tout le monde pour
acheter trois quatre ou cinq livres par
mois
bah c'est merveilleux oui vous pensez
qu'on aurait envie de lire comment vous
pensez que on aura envie de lire après
comment dire vrai c'est pas vrai
qu'est-ce que j'en suis persuadé parce
que je pense qu'en plus les auteurs
comme les comme les éditeurs français et
résonna et ne vont pas se lancer dans
une publication effrénée de récits plus
ou moins sordides sur le coronavirus le
coc vie
le le confinement il est confinement je
pense que les gens ont besoin de lire
autre chose et c'est tout l'intérêt de
la fiction et de l'immense catalogue et
de la richesse incroyable de la
production globale mondiale bien
évidemment mais surtout et d'abord de la
production française qui est d'une
richesse et il ya tout et tout est
disponible tout tout est à lire dans
tous les gens dans tous les formats et à
tous les prix
donc on a un réseau en france et 1 et a
dû lire qui est activement
extraordinaire donc il n'ya pas de crise
de l'offre
il peut y avoir par exemple une crise de
l'eau de temps en temps la télévision
sur des qualités de programme aidera le
livre ça n'existe pas il ya maintenant
il y avait 2 ans perd cadets justement
cette crise est ce que sur les rapports
de travail on a vu ba la vague le
télétravail pendant les semaines dans
les semaines qui se sont écoulées
est ce que ça va changer quelques jours
dans les relations du travail dans
l'évaluation d'entreprises à la
distanciation le télétravail sur ce
sujet oui je pense que ça va changer
mais je ne sais pas si c'est aussi une
bonne chose parce qu'il va falloir que
les entreprises gèrent le pays travaille
parce qu'il ya plein d'entreprises qui
ont découvert le télétravail qui ne le
faisait pas auparavant et qui ont
l'intention de le poursuivre même une
fois que tout ira bien si ce n'est que
le télétravail est encadré et que ce
n'est pas une bonne chose non plus
d'avoir quelqu'un en télétravail enclin
toutes les sociétés qui auparavant avait
mis en place le télétravail c'était un
télétravail d'une journée par semaine et
guère plus ensuite sur la reprise en
tant que telle je vois que ne serait-ce
que le niveau de mon cabinet donc je
suis employeur nous sommes en de la
prestation sociale la prestation de
services et nous sommes 10 j'ai dû faire
une note
anticiper la reprise que je vais
remettre à l'ensemble du personnel du
cabinet qui s'appelle les principes de
bonne conduite au sein du cabinet et si
je faisais tout le tour les obligations
que
nous avons en tant qu'employeur afin de
protéger notre responsabilité qu'elles
soient civiles ou pénales même sur la
mise en danger d'autrui
j'ai lu faire une note
avec 18 points donc vous imaginez que
sur un cabinet on n'est que 10 des
avocats qui sont libéraux et je n'ai que
trois salariés gênante en 18 mois vous
imaginez ils n'avaient pas entreprises
industrielles avec 500 1000 1500 2000
ouvriers sur va sur le site
donc ça c'est une première difficulté
puis ensuite va falloir faire respecter
la distanciation
j'ai vu un reportage d'hier sur la
reprise de renault puisque renault a
repris déjà l'activité avec des mesures
très contraignantes mais intelligente
ils ont fait un accord avec les
syndicats quatre syndicats sur cinq ont
signé et celui qui n'a pas signé le
syndicat qui n'a pas signé c'est la cgt
mais sur des points
peut-être pas idiot mais à de dire ah
bah oui mais une voiture allait toucher
park lane on fabrique une voiture et
donc on n'a pas la certitude qu'il n'y a
pas de navires us qui peut être traîné
sur une carrosserie
donc certes mais dans ce cas là on
rouvrira jamais parce que ça peut
arriver n'importe où à dire bah oui mais
à voir les poids disque sur l'expert
donc ce que je dis c'est que vous voyez
là voire à des relations sociales de
mélo sow et patron qui va mais il faut
prendre un maximum de précautions
en même temps j'ai impossible c'est un
palace c'est paralysant si on impose une
obligation de résultat donc on a déjà
des ordonnances qui ont été rendus en
france qui disent que sinon une
possibilité d'une obligation de moyens
renforcés et pas de résultat parce que
le résultat c'est catastrophique et
jamais jamais et qu'on aime assez tard
ouvrir à jamais son théâtre il a une
obligation de résultat pour la santé la
sécurité de ses salariés de des
personnes des tiers qui viennent pendant
théâtre serait une catastrophe
je veux juste dire une petite chose je
viens de voir passer à côté un collectif
d'acteurs
c'est sur la culture un collectif
d'acteurs qui disent
monsieur le président de la république
cet oubli de millions de gens qui pour
parer la culture est paru le et ça va
publier dans le monde donc c'est ya
jeanne balibar catherine deneuve et
c'est ta d'acteurs qui demande au
président de la république de prendre en
conséquent en considération si la
culture est surtout de pouvoir
poursuivre les droits des intermittents
du spectacle sur les conditions
d'intermittents du spectacle enfant
voilà juste pour dire que ça bouge bien
du côté de la culture ou pas allez on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé jusqu'à présent
n'en parle
le duster également sur ses fans vous
est arrivé de faire le le le
le cours de première année
d'introduction au droit de demander un
amphithéâtre 2002 ils perdent le but
d'étudier comment ça va se passer
l'entraînement d'octobre et il va bien
falloir trouver oscille encore des modes
de fonctionnement différent oui patrie
d'une part c'est ce qui se passe depuis
le 15 mars
l'université et fonctionne toujours mais
elle fonctionne c'est le thème consacré
qui n'est pas satisfaisant dans plus
mais c'est celui ci fonctionne en mode
dégradé
c'est à dire en mode minimaliste en
réalité c'est que nous fonctionnons
comme nous pouvons comme nous le ouvrons
on s'aperçoit d'une chose ce qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas de mon point de vue une
surprise c'est que l'enseignement à
distance
sun ne fonctionne pas c'est une
imposture absolu rien ne remplace et que
ce soit je pense de l'école primaire
jusqu'à l'enseignement supérieur choses
rien ne remplace le contact physique
entre le professeur et les élèves et les
étudiants
ce que ce que met en exergue de ce cet
enseignement à distance
c'est ce dont parle gros sous tout à
l'heure pour en parler tous ses ce sont
les inégalités les inégalités
culturelles intellectuelles social
économique c'est à dire que ceux qui
s'en sortent sont
les étudiants qui sont déjà avancés dans
leur cursus pour les étudiants de
première voie bleue deuxième année c'est
extrêmement compliqué et ceux qui s'en
sortent sont les étudiants qui
bénéficient déjà la capitale culturelle
familiale déjà pas mal pas mal acquis
seconde observation nous nous
travaillons d'ores et déjà sur le
scénario d'une rentrée universitaire à
distance qui se sentiraient donc un
premier semestre à distance et de dire
jusqu'en janvier 2021 ce n'est qu'une
hypothèse mais au moins nous essayons de
le préparer ce scénario le plus en amont
possible pour ne pas être pris au
dépourvu
comme ça peut être le cas dans les dix
premiers jouent ce continent qui ont
entamé le le confinement est temps de
quitter donc si vous vous demandez à
chacun d'entre vous au fond peut-être
votre souhait bas pour l'aide pour les
semaines pour les boîtiers qui viennent
peut-être florence mercadé d'accessoires
de la pire parce que je suis pas très
optimiste
ross est effectivement parler de révolte
sociale et compte tenu des effectivement
des licenciements qui vont intervenir la
économique je suis déjà saisi pour faire
des plans de sauvegarde pour l'emploi
c'est à dire des licenciements de plus
de 20 personnes sur plus de 10 evora
même beaucoup donc voilà je suis pas
très optimiste sur la reprise des
entreprises beaucoup de l'entreprise et
des entreprises importantes ont des
difficultés donc là sur ce sujet là je
ne suis pas très optimiste
et effectivement il ya de la délation il
ya des gens qui sont insupportables ya
des gens charmants
il ya des gens qui y avoir une fracture
péril la société qui m'inquiète qui
m'inquiète beaucoup pour et de toute
manière les financiers ne vont pas
changer y avoir toujours des lobbys et
puis je pense que malheureusement tout
ce qui va être environnement va être le
sujet jours
jean charles banny ben moi je ne ferais
que me répéter je veux vivre et non pas
survivre donc je souhaite que ce
confinement s'arrête et et je n'ai pas
envie qu'on continue cette émission
pendant dix ans façon academy les neuf
oui mais voyez qu'on aille personnes
alors voilà donc dans nos dans nos
échanges
c'est déjà beaucoup plus distendus on
n'est pas face à face jeudi en parlent
les uns après les autres on est on ne
peut pas se couper la parole en fin de
cdd avec sa serrure bête va écouter que
cette période fasse naître pour chacun
c'est une soif d'être ensemble qu'elles
fassent prendre conscience de notre
interdépendance mais également je pense
que cette responsabilité que nous
prenons tous pour éviter la propagation
de la maladie nous l'apprenions aussi
dans d'autres combats
voilà je crois que c'est ça ça doit être
une d une des grandes leçons de cette de
cette période là que nous sommes en
train de vivre
nous avons aussi le pouvoir de une porte
d'agir stéphane rousson oui patrice une
une précision sur laquelle je voulais
revenir c'est que tout à l'heure moi
rien ne me dit qu'il s'agissait de
francis huster
il me semble vous avoir reconnu en début
de confinement parce que vous aviez
moins de cheveux je trouve plus jamais
comment surjouée
sûr mais je pense que cette période
extraordinaire on revient au théâtre
antique vous avez avec le masque qui
absolument démasquer cet automne d'où a
été tiré d'ailleurs le concept juridique
de personnes donc ça c'était tout à fait
passionnant mais travailler parce qu'il
me semble que vous pouvez vraiment être
meilleurs mots sur ce que vous suggérez
tout à l'heure un veut d'abord un peu
d'humilité et puis on avance
empiriquement pragmatiquement au jour le
jour je je je doute que le monde d'après
soit super différent de ce qu'il était
avant pour beaucoup de choses ce n'est
pas souhaitable pour d'autres aspects ça
le serait en revanche mais j'ai fermé je
ne suis pas naïve
j'aurais juste un petit conseil quand
même à donner à ce gouvernement c'est
que je pense que c'est le moment ou
jamais de mettre en place le revenu
universel
ça ça va permettre de limiter un petit
peu la casse sociale au moins pendant un
certain temps
à situation exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles
ils ont parlé de guerre donc l'après
guerre doit être aussi à la hauteur de
ce qu'on appelle on a voilà deux de ce
qui s'est passé au niveau de la guerre
et puis bah j'espère que oui on aura
tous comme comme disait mon sens un tout
petit peu de d'humilité conviendra un
peu plus d'humilité pour comprendre que
la nature reprendra toujours ses droits
et donc il faut qu'on se comporte en
fonction sur le plan écologique
excepté le dernier de ces démissions à
christophe mort il ya pas de vie sans
risque
voilà c'est une belle cote
merci merci infiniment à tous et par là
j'espère on se retrouve très vite invité
évidemment à venir dans le nouveau né ou
repas femme intrépide pour une nouvelle
édition
merci à tous
[Musique]